salut salut
congrès des ventes dont je t'ai parlé et
ben apparemment je vais devoir y aller
en fin de compte pourquoi
je crois qu'ils ont pensé à moi c'est
tout je t'aime Alice mon bel amour
je suis contente de vous voir
joyeux anniversaire
à toi
allez est-ce que ça va désolé c'est
juste si mon
belle fille
avez-vous vu cette jeune fille non on
est arrivé seulement hier
salut
mon âge je t'entends bien
je vais peut-être devoir partir plus tôt
privé depuis quand il est plus important
que nous à tes yeux
le droit d'être en colère tu as mentir à
propos de quoi j'ai pas dit que j'étais
ici
te voilà ma belle
on savait pas que tu venais je suis sur
calice va tout m'expliquer
parce que tu regrettes de m'avoir mentir
comment on est censé être heureux
ensemble si on peut passer faire
confiance
comment Simon a su que tu étais ici il a
eu mes courriels
[Musique]
te regarde pas
vraiment il me rend heureux
[Musique]
pourquoi tu lui as menti
qu'elle te connaissait pas vraiment
[Musique]
j'essaie de te prouver que je t'aime
réellement
mon bel amour